I'll just tell you we've been to the
bottom of the oceans we've been to
ancient Greek mythology we've been to
the past the future flash into the
digital world with cyborg we still gotta
go to space so the Green Lantern's in
the Green Lantern Corps will be coming
to join the Justice of humor that's
every kid's dream see all those Justice
League characters together in Green
Lantern's a big party
you
oh my god youtubers they finally
confirmed they're doing Green Lantern
Corps although it sounds like they
always plan on doing it so I'll explain
what's going on there is a new round of
the flash ring giveaway going on all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a green lantern comment on
this video will say like leave the
person that you want them to cast as Hal
Jordan and Jon Stewart be sure to click
that Bell to enable alerts so that you
don't miss anything so many questions
this is so great I'm so excited that
they're finally doing this again and it
sounds like they're going to take their
time get it right so there are a couple
of things we know a couple things we
don't know so just counting down number
they call it lethal weapon in space what
does that mean so if you haven't watched
that movie it's actually really good it
was made by Richard Donner the man
behind the Christopher Reeve Superman
the good Christopher Reeve Superman
films so this is really cool history
with DC Comics Geoff Johns and Richard
Donner that goes way beyond the DC
Comics films but that's kind of another
story Mel Gibson and Danny Glover's
characters are too old gunslinger type
cops who are forced to answer the call
again so that makes it sound like the
Green Lantern Corps movie is not going
to be a straight-up origin story they'll
have to have elements of the origin like
Jason Momoa says the Aquaman movie will
be all about his history and where he's
going next so it's the same thing with
the Green Lantern Corps movie even
though based on the Lethal Weapon pitch
they'll have already been Green
Lantern's for a period of time like
they'll be disillusioned grizzled
something crazy will happen they'll have
to answer the call again so number nine
what does that say about the plot
because lethal weapon implies like a
certain progression of character it
actually bears a little bit of
resemblance in the Sinestro arc in the
comics so you've probably heard of him
or you seen a picture but if you don't
know his backstory he's basically a
comrade-in-arms who turns evil and
becomes one of their greatest villains
their greatest hero who became their
greatest villain so it's this really
tragic story but that's kind of what
happens during lethal weapon' so the big
antagonist of the movie turns out to be
someone who used to be one of their
comrades
so it's a very Sinestro type story
number eight this will make you feel a
little better too they said the story is
from Geoff Johns who did Green Lantern
Reaper the Sinestro Corps war
he did a lot of great Green Lantern
books did a lot of great flash books
he's kind of the guy at DC Comics that
came up taking really old characters
that weren't cool anymore in making them
cool again so he's doing the exact same
thing right now with DC rebirths and
we're now like full in the era of geoff
johns at DC films so number seven how is
this going to tie in with the Justice
League movie in the other DC film they
haven't really said when it's going to
come but when you look at the IMDB it
just reads 2020 IMDB is not the most
reliable place for information like that
that's probably just a placeholder I
would expect it to fall sometime near
after the second Justice League film
so that's 2019 so 2020 doesn't sound too
unrealistic but because it's so far out
we'll have already gotten to Justice
League films meaning they'll have formed
they'll have had their second adventure
we may have even seen Darkseid at that
point meaning that the stories are
becoming more galactic in nature
providing for the entry point of the
Green Lantern Corps but that also means
as is tradition that they'll have
introduced the character before then in
some sort of cameo or some small scenes
so that you're aware of the concept
before the actual movie comes out most
people know who Green Lantern is but a
lot of people probably have never read a
Green Lantern comic book so you just
kind of need to remind the world that
hey this is the character this is what
it looks like in this universe we're
going to be seeing a movie from him in a
couple more years
number six just to clarify this is not
just a Hal Jordan film this is going to
be Hal Jordan in Jon Stewart
like I said lethal weapon in space that
doesn't mean that they're both going to
be on the edge of retirement one's going
to be suicidal they're not going to be
exactly like the Lethal Weapon
characters but they'll be partners who
aren't necessarily the best of friends
but become comrades through their
adventure trying to fight Sinestro or
whatever big space threats that are is
but when you get into the Green Lantern
Corps you start talking about the war of
light the spectrum of emotions so you
get pretty crazy with the types of
stories you can tell so number five what
is it going to look like if you've seen
the guardians of the galaxy movie in how
different it feels and looks from the
other earth-based Avengers films that's
kind of be the disparity between Green
Lantern Corps in the other earth-based
see films I mean I think before
guardians of the galaxy was as big a
success as it eventually became people
were afraid of doing really weird things
like that in movies like hey can we
spend 150 million dollars on a talking
tree in a talking raccoon well people
care about that
turns out they will so okay it's
probably safe to do some of the crazier
Green Lantern stuff as long as you do it
right so number four what about story
arcs well I think there'll be elements
from Emerald dawn
maybe Emerald dawn - we just shows some
of the times at Hal Jordan spent in
prison after he had been parallax so
Emerald dawn was sort of like a
retelling of his origin story how he
became a Green Lantern so you learn
about his tutelage under Sinestro how he
learns that Sinestro is a hardliner
and keeps his iron fist on his own
people of coreg are Sinestro's exiled
from the Green Lantern Corps because
he's been using fear to oppress his
people when really he said that he's
been using it to protect them so that
sets the stage for him learning about
the rest of the emotional spectrum
creating the Sinestro Corps there's rage
greed fear willpower hope compassion in
love so if you've never read it it's way
too early for blackest night or
brightest day or even war of life I feel
like what they'll do is they'll set the
stage for like a very very distant
future crossover movie with the Justice
League so they can actually make the
title of the movie Justice League war of
light that actually a pretty epic movie
to go see in like another six or seven
years but that's like way way down the
road so I think they're just laying
groundwork for that in order to do that
you have to tell a little bit of Green
Lantern's origin story sinestro's origin
story let everybody know who the
villains and the heroes are what the
stakes are so they probably mixed and
matched a lot of elements from these
really classic titles to tell you who
these characters are without having to
hold your hand like you're watching
Sesame Street or some children's
programs so it'll be a lot of fun the
lethal weapon just makes me feel like
it'll be as a slightly darker tone
slightly more adult version of Green
Lantern which I feel like we all want
number three what about crossover
characters this is going to be the first
Green Lantern Corps film are there going
to be any other humans and it besides
how Jordan and John
Durer well they'll probably have a brief
cameo from at least one or two Justice
League members because we'll have
already seen to Justice League films so
they'll probably have a pre-existing
relationship the Justice League will
probably know who how Jordan and John
Stewart are but the whole idea with
doing Green Lantern Corps is that you
have all of space to play with so just
like guardians of the galaxy isn't
really connected to the earth-based
Avengers films in a really big way I
think it's going to be the same deal
with Korean Lantern Corps like it'll be
off in its own thing even though there
is connective tissue
number two who are they going to get so
I feel like casting Jon Stewart is going
to be way easier than casting Hal Jordan
because everybody still remembers Ryan
Reynolds I'm sure Deadpool is going to
make a whole bunch more Green Lantern
jokes in the Deadpool sequel but for Jon
Stewart I feel like a dress Elba would
absolutely crush it especially if
Murtagh in rig style he's seen a lot of
like he's been around the block a
couple times it's not like a brand new
Green Lantern but I know there have been
a lot of jokes about Armie Hammer
potentially being Green Lantern they
were trolling people on Twitter just a
little bit I don't think that's the case
I don't think that they're casting him
as Green Lantern I think they were just
hanging out a little bit but people
freaked out when both geoff johns in joe
manganiello followed him on twitter but
i think that was about something
separate so you guys can let me know in
the comments who do you want to play Hal
Jordan and who do you want to play Jon
Stewart my number one thing though is
that I hope we get like a short film
like a five minute introduction sequence
or even ten minutes where they do gang
sets tail which tells the story of the
very early days of the Green Lantern
Corps so you learn about the Manhunters
you learn about how they chose to
harness the power of will you get this
grand sense of history of the galaxy
it's so much bigger than the stuff that
you see in Justice League is this huge
concept it provides the back door for
things like blackest night brightest day
and even the anti-monitor
which you know I don't think that'll
ever get to him in the movies because
he's such a ridiculous character he's
ridiculously overpowered but if they
ever do crisis on Infinite Earths in the
movies I think it's more likely they
would turn that into an animated movie
but you guys can let me know do you feel
like if they can get Green Lantern Corps
right and they have like a real
good Justice League franchise that
they'll even try to do crisis on
Infinite Earths
in like 7 or 10 years way down the road
the whole concept just sounds too crazy
for them to even try it so I'll be ok if
they don't so there was so much comic
book news for Marvel and DC defenders
all kinds of stuff that dropped today
I'll try to get through it as fast as
possible I have a defenders
behind-the-scenes teaser video that I'll
post tomorrow morning along with the
breakdown of all the informations they
dumped so it's going to be a really
awesome weekend I'll try to get through
all the videos as fast as possible while
you guys wait for that to post you can
click here for the new Wonder Woman
trailer learn all about Ares the God of
War and you can click here for my top 50
characters that are going to be an
infinity war thank you so much for
watching everybody
since I thought I'll see you guys
tonight
Oh